what up space fam goes in here from
anime outpour and i am back at it again
to discuss the latest
truly mind-blowing developments in the
one piece story this one was not only
crazy it gave me goosebumps
so make sure to stay tuned for the
epicness that is this chapter
if you enjoy seeing these one-piece
reviews on the channel and want to keep
them coming
show one piece some love by smashing
that like button turning it blue like
frankie's hair
and let's see if we can beat last time
where we got 4100 likes
if you haven't yet now's a good time to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell or you will miss
future one piece videos
as you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where you can find videos
about the yonko warlords
supernovas and much more link in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is called my name
and we will see the significance of that
as we move forward
some epic moments have revolved around
names in pop culture
like the whole i am spartacus or this is
sparta
whether it's a name of a person or a
place there is a lot of significance in
a name
in romeo and juliet juliet says that a
rose by any other name
would smell as sweet implying that a
name is not important
it's just something superficial but is
that true the question will be explored
in this chapter one piece and don't
assume that shakespeare agreed with
juliet either
keep in mind juliet wasn't a wise sage
but a 13 year old girl and she and romeo
died in part because of their last names
so let's see what's actually in a name
this chapter begins at the back entrance
with the red scabbards meeting up
kinemon and danger are in the house they
look epic af
as they walk between the fellow
scabbards here oda is clearly channeling
those
classic japanese samurai films in a way
this whole arc is a kind of tribute to
them
aesthetically and thematically with the
theme of revenge being prevalent
last chapter it looked like kunjuro was
killed but it was shown in an artistic
way
where we couldn't be absolutely sure
here we do see clearly that conjuro is
on the ground bleeding and it would do
no good for the forces to get caught up
at such an early opponent
when they got so many difficult fights
ahead of them the scabbards reminisce
about old times
when things were simpler and everyone
was more innocent they laughed together
and were silly
odin was there and kendra hadn't been
revealed to be a traitor yet
there is no going back to that idyllic
vision of the past
and that's part of the reason that the
death of kunjuro is hard for them to
bear it's another reminder that the old
golden days
are gone never to return and by the way
if you guys do want to see a video
specifically about all of the nine
scabbards and their powers
if you just need a refresher check that
out in the description i'll put it there
but moving on
kiku and rhizo cry and even kinemon
shows respect to his old comrade
kanjuro by placing his hat over his dead
face even if he did betray them the
feelings they had for conjuror were real
but there's no time to fully grieve they
must keep moving
kinemon and denjiro are surprised and
delighted to see ezo
and i think that ezo being here works
perfectly they were denying scabbards
and kundra betrayed them and died but
eazl was also a vassal of odin
before he joined whitebeard's crew and
thus he can fill in as the ninth
scabbard
i don't always mention word for word
what the characters say but i really
like this moment between ezo and kinemon
kinemon says
this is a good place to take a last
stand wouldn't you agree
and iso replies i have escaped from much
worse
end quote this one panel catches the
bravery of the samurai how they are
ready for their last stand they are
ready to die fighting for what they
believe in
and it also reminds us that eazl is a
legendary figure
associated with whitebeard called the
strongest man in the world and when ezo
says that he escaped from much worse
it's actually likely to be true we can
only imagine the crazy things ezo
has been through with whitebeard's crew
and fighting kaido's crew is not
necessarily that of the ordinary for a
whitebeard pirates division commander
however not having whitebeard and the
entire crew present and throwing big mom
into the mix for the enemies
nonetheless makes it a doozy of a
situation and one we can't help but be
excited to experience
we then jump to kaido who as you'll
remember gave the samurai
of orochi and ultimatum they can die
with their master
or join him and take over the world now
that's probably the most biased sentence
ever because on the one hand you can
rule the world or
on the other hand you can die but kaido
again says something interesting that
feeds into his sense of honor
that i keep talking about again this
honor is not stereotypical like that of
a knight in shining armor but
he does seem to have his own moral
compass and he seems to be grieved
and troubled when he acts against it
like when he took advantage of a
distraction to defeat odin
kaido turned out to be a complicated
character despite being portrayed as a
drunken meat head initially
and that goes to oda's credit kaido says
that he understands how much the samurai
value loyalty
and that the ones who choose to die with
orochi will have
all of his respect this isn't
machiavellian at all
why would he want to lose capable men
but he can't help himself
he actually hopes people will choose an
honorable path
even if it could be to his detriment but
alas there are few honorable samurai
left in this world and all of the 5000
ninja and all the 5 000 samurai
jump ship and pledge their loyalty to
kaido some even say
oh well after their master died boss
hyogoro is appalled
despite the fact that he didn't like
orochi he is disgusted that all of these
men have forgotten the warrior code
everyone is looking out for themselves
grasping on to a life even if it means a
life with no honor
nami and karachon are in big mom's grasp
as shinobu is charged with rescuing momo
and points for nami too
on a superficial level since the
beginning she's portrayed herself as
someone selfish who's always after money
and willing to use others to get what
she wants but in reality she is a great
person
and she thinks to herself about
momonosuke's safety rather than just her
own
even though she is in serious trouble i
definitely prefer that kind of character
to someone who acts like they're
selfless but is actually
selfish when it comes down to it nami is
like the anti-that person
and i like those kinds of characters a
lot the kinds of characters who downplay
how actually good they are as shinobu
moves towards momo she thinks to herself
that odin knew
that orochi was useless and that he had
to take out
kaido from the start without kaido
backing him orochi would have been a
piece of cake to deal with we jumped to
kaido talking to momonosuke
and this is my favorite conversation in
this chapter
kaido actually gives momonosuke a chance
to get off the hook he says that an
incompetent brat like him can't be
odin's son
kylo mentions that he saw momo in the
burning castle 20 years ago when he
chose to let him live
he points out how back then when kaido
asked the little boy his name
he just kept talking about how scared he
was momo felt bad about the moment too
even though he was just a kid in this
moment now in the present
actually gives him a chance to redeem
himself for how he acted back then kaido
straight up tells momonosuke that the
execution will be cancelled
if he just lies about his identity all
he has to do is say he's not odin and
toki's son
once again like 20 years ago kaido asks
momo
his name and just as we're about to get
his answer
we jump to luffy we're getting
cliffhanger seption
with oda in these chapters but it
definitely does keep things tense and
fast paced
yamato says that she doesn't think the
shackles will actually explode
but luffy should throw them away when he
breaks them off
just in case and luffy succeeds in
getting them off but
before we see the explosion or lack
thereof we
move on to flying six members both who's
who
and ulti realize that luffy and yamato
are heading to the activity hall
suggesting that they're all going to be
packed in close quarters
real soon a battle royale of epic
proportions usopp and chopper get some
screen time while chopper cries about
the dangers and how the situation
isn't good at all usopp is acting like
quite the brave warrior
of course he's nervous but he's rushing
to save momo and he's comforting chopper
at the same time props to usopp he's
come a long way towards his dream
of becoming a brave warrior of the sea
then everything gets real crazy the
scabbards are in the house
so are law kid and zorro we finally
return to momonosuke as he reminisces
about being told
that he will be the man who carries the
country of wano on his shoulders he
thinks of luffy will confidently
proclaimed that he would be the pirate
king he thinks about when his dad told
him that his name means the peerless one
he has a huge decision to make a life
and death one will he take the path of
the samurai with no code of honor
who join whoever is in power or will he
follow in the example of his parents and
luffy
who did what was right and what they
believed in even if it meant risking
their lives
finally momo says that his name is
momonosuke kozuki
he says i am the one who will become
wano shogun
at this point i got goosebumps beat up
bad and with his life on the line
the so-called strongest creature in the
world right in front of him and he
confidently says his name to
everyone he chooses to risk an honorable
death
rather than cling to a life like a
coward without honor in this case
momonosuke
saying his real name is his ultimate
redemption the ultimate courageous act
which
fully pays respect to his parents who
sacrificed their lives to save him
denying his name would be like denying
his
parents and denying his duty and momo
refuses to do that no matter what
just like momo drew inspiration from
luffy and shows bravery and honor
we can draw inspiration from this little
kid who showed courage
in the face of the strongest creature in
the world people are shocked and laugh
but kaido was clearly bothered he didn't
want to kill the kid and perhaps it also
irritates him
how much momo is like odin and how
despite
all of his power he cannot break the
little kid's spirit
after this moment of redemption momo
says he can finally face his parents in
the afterlife proudly
yes he does cry but he can't really help
that what he could do was decide his
path
and he chose the manliest one possible
so those are
manly tears dammit huge props to
momonosuke
he made us all very proud we then see an
explosion and luffy and yamato are
behind it
yamato is furious that her father was
willing to actually kill her and she
says that she gets it now
and that kaido is no longer her father
she's crying clearly emotional
but who can blame her this is about as
bad as daddy issues go this was a
significant realization though
because it should have cut yamato's ties
to her dad
so she can fully focus on the fight and
not hesitate as a result of sympathy
or unresolved feelings it turns out
luffy made it in time and he says that
and i quote
the decisive battle is about to start
end quote
remove all hype limiters that is what we
needed to hear
and now all systems are go the red
scabbards sneak up behind kaido
everyone is shocked especially queen in
his stereotypical over-the-top fashion
jack is shocked to see the mink rulers
alive and will hopefully get to see them
work together to even the score with him
i can't wait for that
ezo as cool as ever shoots king's sword
out of his hand
king the top all-star ezo just keeps
getting cooler and cooler in my books he
really does
kaido notices kyoshiro aka denjuro and
we see dangerous face
this whole time he has been serving
those he hates the most and now it
finally all pays off
with this single blow or at least he
hopes
at first kaido seems confident but he
gets a flashback of odin
and fury and fear seem to enter his eye
the red scabbard scream
tsunachi as they all move in for the
kaido kill together
and tsunachi is their battle cry that
strengthens the heart
and that they use in the past bringing
the past and all of its significance
directly into the present action and
that my friends
is the end of this mind-blowing chapter
obviously it would be hard to believe
that kaido would die from this attack
but the red scabbards are really going
for the kill
which is crazy and technically until we
see the next chapter
we have no idea how this is gonna end
this arc keeps getting better and better
and once again i must say that this is
my favorite wano chapter to date
the goosebump inducing feels got me as
well as the significance
of the past and how all that weight is
exploding into the present moment
in this last stand amazing simply an
amazing
chapter and i don't even have to tell
you that i'm looking forward to the next
one
you already know what it is as always
let me know your thoughts on this
chapter
and give me your theories for what we
can expect to happen next
in the comments if you did enjoy this
review and want to keep them coming
show one piece some love by smashing
that like button
turn it blue and share this video with
your cultured
pirate friends if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one-piece videos and reviews
and as you impatiently wait for the next
chapter to drop
remember to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i got videos about
the yonko warlords
supernovas and more link in the
description
feel free to leave suggestions for one
piece topics you are acing up to see
and that my friends was in fact a bad
one-piece related pun
that i used instead of the words burning
up a very special thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
one tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans steven ingrada alolan atem
world steelers acquire respect pate
heffa jonathan king brandon of viles
papa smurf the school bus king riser
emperor otaku ricardo martinez thomas
jones
ken mono michael hyde and jaden the
vector controller
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings eldris
anatoly kazatsky angel cruz cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia actor
jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie park sodie r12
rethuan day aura
kraken aurel's deadly saint and stern
hawkins thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support morbid by going over to
patreon.com anime pro and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do sell your gear name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to a private patron only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
link in the description if you're
interested
you can also now join the youtube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you